this is where global emissions are today
and this is where global emissions need
to get to by 2050 to stop what
scientists say will be catastrophic
climate change and this space here
is what's called the emissions gap
closing it might sound simple enough but
time is running out and the blame game
is already well underway
[Music]
the paris agreement is our best hope of
stopping the planet from dangerous
global warming but it's just a first
step nearly 200 nations pledged to limit
temperatures from rising above 2 degrees
celsius or if possible
1.5 degrees and those countries are
going to be debating about who should do
what for many years to come
here's the problem each set their own
plans and together aren't doing enough
to cut greenhouse gases in time
emissions fell dramatically in the
pandemic but carbon dioxide lingers in
the atmosphere for hundreds of years so
a temporary drop won't make much
difference to the overall trend
scientists say the world needs to reach
net zero emissions by 2050.
some nations like bhutan have already
met their goal decades early but others
are dragging their heels particularly
those whose economies rely on oil and
gas such as russia and saudi arabia
then there are the developing nations
like indonesia and bangladesh who say
they can only consider tougher emissions
targets if rich countries deliver on
their promise to raise more money to
help them
there is a lot of disagreement over who
is to blame for all the emissions in the
atmosphere and how some countries
already got rich from polluting
china was responsible for just this
portion of emissions in the past
but today it's the world's largest
polluter so they agreed each country
would come up with their own voluntary
plan about what they thought they could
realistically do
these plans are called nationally
determined contributions they aren't
enforced and there are no penalties for
failing to meet them right now countries
have targets for 2030 and have agreed to
meet every few years to make sure
they're on track
and raise their ambition
but as of now emissions are still too
high and according to the united nations
we're heading towards a three degree
rise this century
you